c'était des gens comme ce
pantalon en cuir Henry sur des nuances enveloppantes et Stewart
vivant comme un sauvage dans une veste en cuir
il y a juste ce gamin de toi qui
ne sait rien donc je me sentais comme si je n'étais pas à ma
place et j'allais partout ils le font
aussi plaisir je peux  Je ne crois aucun
autre guitariste britannique des rois de
Londres et a joué avec la police,
puis s'estompe comme ici dans les bloqueurs
et le greffier Henry était notre lien
avec la scène, il avait cette
personnalité engageante et une endurance infatigable,
il serait le dernier homme  debout dans un
bar à thé à Londres d'
accord Henry ton secret est en sécurité
mec sexy
tu